so a little bit moving from sound
communication
to the idea of how uh groups of um
birds are able to
i guess communicate somehow uh to
perform fairly complex algorithms so
bernard
go forward okay can you hear me all
right yeah
okay great so um well first i want to
thank jeffy michael and dave
uh for inviting me to this workshop uh i
mean i knew i would be in for a treat
but it's
i have to say it's been fantastic uh the
talks have been just wonderful i've
learned
a lot of stuff i want to thank you thank
you all for that
i'm not so sure you'll be thanking me
just just as much at the end of my talk
uh because of the uh uh the the
the unclear relevance uh to the topic at
hand of what uh i'm going to say but i
hope that you will
you will find some something of interest
um
along the way uh that is not my real
concern
i have one real concern uh which is your
stomach
because you have you have not had food
uh since breakfast
until i mean unless you took a break uh
somewhere
so it means that you're all in a very
bad mood so if you have a nasty question
to me
don't worry i will interpret it as your
stomach
speaking so what am i going to talk
about here
um i'm a computer scientist so i have to
start with a turing machine
uh alan turing defined uh the concept of
universal computation
and started the field of computer
science uh
what's remarkable about his construction
of turing machine which i'm sure you've
seen
before and i don't have to go uh over
this is how lame
it is in fact in alan turing's uh
world view there are two things there's
information that's what's on the tape
and then that information gets processed
there's a processing so there's this
sort of binary thing
and it never asks the question but how
do we get
the information to be processed how's
the communication between all this it
just
simply pumps and that's a stroke of
genius because
that's how the field had to be started
out by ignoring communication
now once we started having some kind of
a theory about what was going on
then starting in the 50s i would say
with information theory uh but then
later on
uh with uh the emergence of networks
uh and things like cryptography uh the
the concept of communication become
increasingly
important now if you're a software uh i
mean if you're a computer
uh engineer the this is really the issue
of architecture
i mean obviously you're turning no
computer looks like this turing machine
uh except in some abstract fashion a
computer is a very complicated beast
unlike
that machine and it's complicated
because
it has to deal with communication mostly
now there also
emerged a branch of theoretical computer
science called
communication complexity uh which took
this very original
uh angle in my view which is to actually
go inside the processing element and say
you know what
if you really want to understand
processing uh
then you have to start thinking about
communication that processing can be
cut apart can be dissolved into
processes of communication
uh it's hard to explain how brilliant
this concept
has turned out to be um so it's really a
triad there
there are three things going on here uh
information processing and communication
that's really what computer
computing is all about um now in the
world of
biology there are some similarities uh
so just to pick an example that you've
never heard of
uh it's some kind of strange virus
of very little importance uh what could
happen is that this virus gets into your
so let me tell you a little story uh
from a sort of biological
uh language so the uh these
viruses get through your nose or through
your mouth
and then they go into your lungs through
the lining of your lungs the epithelial
cells
and then magically uh they get inside
the cell now the way they do this is
because they
they have the spike proteins this little
which gives you the name
corona virus and then and then they bind
to these
enzymes these receptors called ace2 uh
and uh once it's once the binding takes
place
then the magic of chemistry uh pulls
this thing down
through the membrane inside the cell now
a quick point which is important
uh why do we have ace2 what does this
thing do this
this thing is in the lungs but it's
everywhere pretty much uh which is why
the covid19 can be such a nasty disease
it's because ace to regulate help
regulates
blood pressure now blood is a
communication process blood is mostly
used to transport things uh
your immune system your your oxygen you
know things like that
uh so it's all about communication now
ace2
makes that communication possible and
unwillingly i guess it
allows the virus to get inside the cell
and then i
you know then typically you would look
at the biochemistry you would say
okay look this virus has a membrane
so all the good stuff that's inside has
to come out and so for this we have to
kill the membrane okay we're going to
lyse it that's lysosome that's
going to do that okay then we are in the
cytoplasm we're not in the nucleus right
now so this virus
what is it going to do now if it was a
normal virus if you try to get into
the nucleus but it's not going to do
that it won't even try to get into the
nucleus and so
what it will do is it is fine magically
some ribosomes out there
and start uh express it starts
translating
producing some proteins now this is very
interesting the proteins
that it reproduces it has lots of choice
because it's a big
genome but it produces polymerase that's
the protein that's used to replace
for doing replication now this is
strange because
viruses typically go inside the nucleus
and they hijack the replicating
the reputation system but that but not
coronal virus chronovirus is going to
replicate itself
by using its own technology it only uses
the uh ribosome
okay fat fine then it just it makes tons
of replications
uh and it now it it can start expressing
all these proteins to make the membrane
to
to transform to make a new viruses to do
that
and i i don't have a picture of the
cytoplasm is is
what's you know outside the nucleus you
know uh in eukaryote cells and it's a
bit complicated it's got all these
organelles and stuff like that
but the point is that these viru these
virus all these are
the genomes the parts of the genome are
going to be traveling
first through something called the er
you you don't have to know what it is
and then magically it's going to go uh
into the golgi apparatus
where it's going to form the membrane
and then finally it's going to hit
against the wall against the membrane
of the cell and it wants to get out and
so there's
exocytosis which will take place again
the magic of chemistry
can explain this entire pathway and this
is extremely complex
and many nobel prizes have gone into
illustrating every
each step now that's the traditional way
of looking at biology but there's a dual
version
which is to say no no the battle
chemistry is not the interesting part
the interesting part is the choreography
how in the world did you get
all this this dance to take place
uh billions of times in a very reliable
fashion yeah i should add one more thing
the coronal virus is very long in fact
it breaks these the famous upper bound
on viral length
uh it's so long that it produces tons of
errors
when it hits the ribosome and it
replicates itself it makes tons of
errors
and so it has to fix this error so it
has an error correcting code
uh mechanism a proofreading mechanism
that
it builds itself that it has its own
proteins
to do that it's quite remarkable
now it's a subtle difference to say you
know let's not just look
at at a bunch of biochemical steps
and study very very carefully all the
equations that explains
those these chemical reactions this is
sort of you know
traditional way i would argue that the
big mystery
is not there the big mystery is how's
the whole thing happening to begin with
how does it know how to find the ace ii
how does it know to find the ribosomes
how does it know to find
all these other stuff that he needs to
find a cell is a very
crowded stuff with all kinds of
irrelevant material for the purposes of
this virus
how the world does it communicate to be
at the right time
at the right place to do the right thing
that is a complete mystery whereas in
biochemistry at least we know a lot of
stuff
or at least biochemists know a lot of
stuff i should not include myself in
that list
uh but the communication is the big
mystery so in that sense it's very
similar
it's very similar to computer science
where where it took a long time to
realize like the hard part
really is communication not processing
um
okay all right a bird i love birds so
this
big little guy handsome little fellow
it's called a starling
and it's a remarkable burst it's like it
likes to fly
uh in big flux now this is a movie you
may have seen before
uh and it's it's just one minute so it
will take too long and i can't
resist uh showing it because
it's it's so spooky like you look at
this
and you can ask so these are starlings
these are the birds that i just
showed and you can ask well how many are
there well nobody knows for sure but
probably this one there's more than one
million uh sometimes up to five million
have been spotted um they never seem to
collide
which means that the birthday paradox is
obviously false however these
birds have never heard of it uh and then
they found this amazing
and now if you are um
[Music]
anyway now you can ask tons of questions
and we don't know the answer like why do
they do this
well there are speculations but
everybody knows for sure anyway they do
this and then they go to bed
um
okay
now this is a big plot but this is not
the biggest okay you have to understand
that there are birds or at least there
used to be birds passenger pigeons
in in the united states that would flock
um
in the billions not the millions in the
billions with the b
uh the flocks were so big that it would
take two weeks
if you happen to be flying over where
you live
which would be very unfortunate for you
for for two weeks you would have these
birds
flying over your thing um
why do they do this now so i watched
movies like this about 15 years ago
a princeton and this this guy ian cousin
who's one of the big experts
on birds i was talking about this and he
never mentioned the word
algorithms but he was really talking
about algorithms so i just became
fascinated and said
wait a minute i we need to understand uh
what's going on
and the good thing when you know nothing
about a topic is that you think
that uh how hard can it be okay and then
but of course then the more you know the
more you realize this
is just hopelessly difficult uh this
thing
um and you also realize you're hardly
the first person
to to make this this point and to work
on it um
now there are three classes families of
approaches to this problem
uh one from physics uh another is a
multi-aging based
system and the other i will not talk
about which is more recent which is
active matter
so let me talk about the first two um
now this is a throwaway comment
our bird's bird brain but it's actually
really fundamental
to this thing because um
i mean to some extent my my big sort of
existential crisis as is contained
in this question which is that
the natural approach to say flocking
okay
it's a sort of occam's razor id where
you are going to try to find so they
have brains
and brains birds have brains and they
have complicated brains and brains are
behind all of that
but you will assume that the brain is
as inactive as possible or rather that
it does the minimalistic thing so maybe
the
the brain can follow two rules three
rules four rules and that's it
you you're going to assume that and that
could be completely wrong in fact i have
great doubts about that i don't
understand
any there's no principle i know of that
says that
when you try to do something very simple
to go from a to b
you will try to minimize the utilization
and the sophistication of your brain i
mean it could be just completely wrong
okay so however that is the basis of
most
work on bird flocking which could also
means that it's totally doomed
but that's a topic if i have time i'll
get back to i still believe
it's the right approach because uh the
brain
and this is not at all a job at
neuroscience or anything
but the brain is incredibly complicated
and so
if you can do something without actually
pretending that there's a brain
uh and you happen to be right this would
be wonderful but if you
actually need to explain something if
you need the full power of the brain
this becomes extremely difficult okay so
let's see what we can do if we assume
that birds are indeed bird brain which
is the brain is almost irrelevant
so statistical mechanics uh like
much uh complex uh systems organs
in physics come from statistical
mechanics in particular
uh the icing model uh so what you have
is a is a set of uh particles
uh and there are basically two forces
that act on them
i don't use the word force in a
technical sense i just mean it's a
metaphor
these particles want to do two things so
in the simplest case the
so-called magnetic case the particles
want to be
similar to their neighbors they want to
be some you know mimetic thing
they just want to do what the neighbors
do they want to do the same on the other
hand
there's a lot of stochasticity there's
lots of um
thermal uh energy in the system so they
also fluctuate a lot
you know depending on how much
temperature there is this
you know they cannot keep up with this
sort of army-like
discipline is the tension between order
and disorder which comes from this the
minimizer the you try to minimize the
energy that's order
and you want to maximize the entropy and
that's uh disorder
and is this conflict between these two
forces if you will
that's the basis of statistical
mechanics and it's a
field that has been extremely successful
one has to admit and
has wonderful ideas uh it's also
possible possible to look at the entire
field
as a branch of probability theory
there's remarkably little physics in it
actually
um that so you have say n um
particles and they have spin so let's
say the the spin is
up or down uh as the pictures uh
represent
so there are two to the n possibilities
and each one has an energy associated
with it we'll see what we do with that
so there are two to the end
numbers uh n is very big
typically and could be avocados number
so this is
a gigantic set okay
and now what you want is find the
probability of being in a particular
configuration where's the probability
i'm going to be in this energy that
energy and that sort of thing
so you have these unknowns these
variables p1 for p2 to the n
and you want to find what they are and
so well there are many possibilities
obviously so
your your goal is to say well there's
one constraint
uh which is there's a minimum there's a
mean energy the
there's an average energy which is set
by the system
you can set it now this is important to
understand that
the energy of the system is not fixed
what's fixed is the average it's it's
because
this is not a closed system this uh
system communicates with the outside
like
they could be a bath outside that you
know they could be air
they could be uh so so there are
molecules
bouncing back and forth and so there's
transfer of energy in and out so you
don't know the energy
is not specified what's specified is the
mean over a certain period of time
all right so so that's why it gives you
this is an interesting problem
it's not uh trivial and if you do the
math it's very simple math and you find
that there's only one solution it's the
boltzmann distribution
and this gives you the probability of
each
uh configuration and uh t is a parameter
that
emerges from this optimization problem
it's a lagrange multiplier
and z is simply there so that these
numbers sum up to one
and z is called the partition function
what's important to understand about the
partition function is that
as a sum it's a gigantic thing because
there are lots of these numbers
tons of them so it's typically
impossible to compute this animal
okay and so all right so um
now in the case of the icing model what
i just told you is a very general thing
but but now in the ic model which has
been studied a lot
and to take the the simplest case the
magnetic case um then we consider that
we have this grid
say in two dimensions uh and the
particles sit
at these nodes uh on the great okay i
think it's a large grade so don't worry
too much
on the boundaries what happens at the
boundaries it doesn't much matter
um and so so so you have uh these
uh uh spins they go up and down
um sorry uh okay so um
so um so now you have to define the
energy
um so the energy is defined by the
hamiltonian
which is a function of these spins of
this
so typically it's plus one minus one
plus one
if it points up and minus one if it
pulls down
and um so this sum just make sure we
understand
uh how this works i'm going to sum over
all the nodes i so these are all these
guys all
other particles i'm just sum over this
for each particle i
there's a set of neighbors okay uh in
this case
uh you have you know eight uh you have
eight neighbors
six and two uh so so you sum over the
neighbors
okay and then you take the um the
product of the spins
all right so uh typically you want the
energy to be very low
and therefore since there's a minus and
j is a coupling constant that's
positive in this case so so you want
this guy to be as big as possible
and so you want these guys to have the
same sign so you want them to be all
plus one or
all minus one but they cannot be all
plus one or l minus one because
because you have these constraints over
the average uh
energy anatomy if you will so anyway you
plug in your boltzmann distribution
and you find this formula okay which
follows
uh directly and again i mean the point
is that
these are each element is very simple
here
but because there's so many of them the
whole thing is very complicated
okay now the many questions you can ask
about this but
in the context of this workshop there's
only only one that
that matters can you use this system
to transmit uh information so let's say
that
you are here and you perturb
these uh these or maybe four of them or
something you have a little perturbation
on this particle all right so maybe you
wait until it's it's at equilibrium the
system is equally
heated so there's the stationary
distribution yeah the boltzmann
distribution is the stationary
distribution so these systems are all at
equilibrium i mean
the entire field assumes equilibrium so
anyway you perturb this guy
say it's minus one and you turn it to
plus one and you want to
know whether uh this this perturbation
will be a code
say on the other side like well this guy
over here or just a question
do you see my arrow i've
i'm sure yeah you say okay good thanks
uh bernard can i just ask you a quick
question
should i keep in my mind an analogy of
this system to these birds where each
uh that a bird is on a vertex here or
so i'm going to get to this in in 10
seconds
yes so you want to know whether
information can go from here to there
and the theory pretty much answers that
question
it tells you in general the answer is no
now think of this term when the
temperature uh
is very low okay so uh it would say
very high so it's uh it's very high
there
there are tons of thermal fluctuations
because sort of
entropy takes over and so these
probabilities are about this
is it's about the uniform distribution
uh basically so
so everything is independent basically
so if you perturb this this has no
effect on anybody else because they all
have their own
independent life okay so when the
temperature is very high
the answer is no and when the
temperature is very low
then the answer is no because when the
temperature is very low
then basically this is gonna this
exponential
is gonna act as a screen as a mask to
pick out the
the lowest energy it's actually going to
drive the system to the lowest possible
energy there's going to be one solution
and and that's where the system is going
to be so this is like a
solid it's like a crystal if you will so
if you take a solid
crystal and you simply a piece of sugar
and you simply perturb one tiny grain
has no effect on the rest so when t is
big or when t is very small
the answer is no this system cannot
transmit information however
there is a magical uh there's a magical
temperature called critical temperature
where uh at that temperature there is
long range correlations so
you can actually use that to transmit
information and this is going to be the
connection to
flocking uh the key thing is
it's a magical number it has to be
fine-tuned
very very carefully okay because uh if
you just try random temperature is never
going to happen
but you have to magically so that's how
phase transitions
occur phase transition here will will be
second order of the
uh uh phase transitions and so
uh it will be a very tiny tiny tiny
range of temperatures all right now the
birds
we're going to use the same idea to
understand birds now
the starting point of this work um well
one of the big big starting points of
work was a heroic
uh effort by a group of people
in rome italy now this is not one paper
with all these people
i'm compiled
most of the authors who've worked on
part or
of this work over five years it's an
enormous amount of effort
that these people did um to
to try to have this analogy with the
icing model now
the thing is birds are hard uh i
appreciated this by talking to people
who actually
uh work with experiments which would not
be me
um you know fish are easier dogs are
easier uh
simply because you know you cannot tell
birds to do what you want them to do
so you simply wait and then birds do
something and you take a video
and then you just simply analyze the
video you're gonna say okay we're gonna
try like
50 takes and see what happens well maybe
you can do it over
50 different days but there's very
little control that you can do with
birds so birds are
i mean i know some of the animals we
heard whales and elephants i'm sure must
be extremely difficult
to handle for similar reasons but i
think burst is the ultimate
you can't even touch them you cannot
it's a
you're totally passive observer here so
anyway so
they took these videos that you don't
have a million here you have like 2 000
or something like that
and then they do the com they did the
computer vision work which
means that you do the registration and
all of that uh
to find the velocity of these birds and
so on and
since you you pretend this is an
equilibrium
uh i mean it's a big uh ask
to think of this in equilibrium but it's
not completely stupid because the
velocities are roughly the same speed
so so you can really look at the
transversal
uh the heading as being the spin uh if
you will and that
you can more or less think of it as
being in equilibrium
so you're going to replicate what we did
before but instead of plus one minus one
what you're going to do is take the
heading so for each bird you take the
velocity divided by its length so this
is just
the you know so this is in three
dimensions so this is a point
on the units on the unit sphere uh
and it's a two-dimensional object and so
this is a vector so you take the
dot product and then that's it this is
gonna give you the probability
so this is a well-known model it's
called the heisenberg model in
statistical physics
and so this is your equivalent
now you can do some some
some first principle if you will uh uh
newtonian
uh analysis of this and you derive this
large found dynamics
so it's just a differential equation
with a with a stochastic term
here that's uh that's just white noise
that you had uh some statisticity
which is essential for uh this entire
approach
um and then what you want to study is
many things
in particular the correlation function
so here's what you do
you take a bird eye and you look at all
these neighbors at distance r
or maybe between distance r and distance
r
plus one meter or something like that so
a tiny
little you know uh ring um and you call
this n sub
i so you take the average uh
uh dot product with bird i
of these other velocities uh i mean
headings
and then you you just take the average
and that's your uh correlation
so if it could be zero it could be
negative you could be positive
and it well it tells you the correlation
between these verbs but it tells you the
correlation at a certain distance
because r can be anything you want
so you do this empirical work again
again i really have to praise the
enormous amount of work this represented
and i have
to give these people an enormous amount
of credit um
anyway they they they plot this curve
which makes physicists very happy
because
of these sort of thing that they love to
see in particular they want to know when
the correlation is zero
and the question is in other words from
here to here is when you can have
communication because there's
correlation so if you perturb something
there's going to be some
echo somewhere uh down up to 10 meters
after 10 meters uh it's going to be lost
okay or some negative correlation but by
and large it's going to be lost
and so uh now if you replicate these
experiments
uh but with different number of birds or
different distances then you find that
this is a linear term in other words
this is a fixed
constant as a factor of 40.
so that means that there is no scale
okay because you
you could call this number here which
must be like 12
to be uh the scale now if you found 12
every time
regardless of the number of birds you
always find well
then that would be the scale of the
systems but but what you find is it's
proportional to the number of birds
in other words there's no scale it's a
skill-free system
which is what you need to have it's a
it's a necessary not sufficient but
necessary condition for
criticality and so at least it tells you
this is scale-free and this
uh makes sense if you think of uh
communication
however in a particular in this
particular case there are two possible
interpretations and i'm not sure the
jury is completely out
on that um one is to say there's
criticality
just like the icing model now there's a
problem with that interpretation
because remember in the ic model there's
a magic temperature
so how in the world do these birds
manage to have some magic
average energy that they have in order
for this to happen
this would be unexplained you would have
to explain how they
engineered this because this when we say
temperature now it's not the temperature
of the of the air
it's it's temperature is in relation to
the energy that they expand
um so that's an explanation that's
that's a little bit uh suspicious
although like sand pile
is these are systems which have
criticality
of self-organized criticality that do
not require fine-tuning so there are
examples
outside the icing model where you do
have criticality without
fine-tuning but anyway it's a little bit
dubious who knows
but there's something that's more likely
which is known as the gold stone mode
and that's something that comes from
quantum mechanics and stuff which says
that when you
when you don't have plus one minus one
but you have a continuous
uh spin so see the spin is is a vector
of in three dimensions of length one
it's a unique vector
so it has all these symmetries of your
symmetries
so the system has continuous symmetries
and therefore there's going to be
symmetry breaking
you know the the birds decide to fly in
this direction and not that direction
there's nothing magical about the
direction they happen to be flying
it's just a breaking of symmetry and
there's all these
symmetries it could go into another
thing and the point is that it requires
no energy to change uh the
this uh common direction of what's a
very
let's say a leader decides to change
so anyway i don't say more about this
there's a
continued debate about this but it's a
good example
where uh with this kind of metaphor
coming from from statistical mechanics
you build this completely
phenomenological system or not
completely but almost
with a little bit of first um first
principle
uh and then you somehow
makes you speculate but i think soundly
speculate about the possibility
what birds have to do to have
communication
across the flock so when because
sometimes a bird said now we're going
left
and they all follow how's that happening
are you because it's not true that he's
the leader it is not true that is
the bird that just happens to be flying
ahead of everybody who calls the shots
that simply is not true experimentally
it's we see that
and there is no broadcasting mechanism
from the outside world
so it's a very interesting scientific
question and and these are possible
answers
who knows however this runs into
problems
when you push this uh this work this
hamiltonian is a quadratic function
and this is what you can show from this
that the information propagates through
diffusion
now if you remember you know your your
chemistry
uh classes diffusion moves at a speed
that um that goes down to zero it's one
over square root of t
so you know the it moves not linearly in
time t but
as the square root so the the larger the
system
the slower the diffusion goes this
contradicts
experiments so they did these
experiments where at some point they
observed the birds and they make
the birds make a very sharp turn and
they want to know why
uh you know what's happening so
um so that again
did all these experiments uh and these
are a picture of the turn of all these
birds
the z direction is interesting they they
do the sharp turn almost in a plane
okay but it's a very very sharp turn and
then they measure
the polarization which is the the
average
uh the length of the average heading
okay so so if this were random this
would be this is like the first fourier
coefficient
if this was random this would be almost
zero and there'd be no polarization but
if the bird decide
to work in the same direction to be
united uh
they need they're very polarized and i
guess
maybe the term is not the right one but
anyway um
oh what did i do here sorry oh yeah um
so
what they found is that there's almost a
linear fit
now if you're a statistician
listening to this you might have some
serious eye rolling
going on here uh okay maybe these two
guys are
outliers who knows but anyway it kind of
fits a line
as with square root of one over y minus
v
so what you find is that the speed is
inversely proportional to square root of
y minus
v so the greater the polarization
the greater the speed which kind of
makes sense when
when when those guys uh decide to
to to be very very united uh in one
direction
then the communication is going to be
super fast
um so anyway these means that the
previous model doesn't work there's no
the previous hamiltonian will not will
simply not give you these results so
when the birds decide to turn
something else is happening these are
the limits of
the statistical mechanics approach
anyway this is some interesting
uh development over several years and
based on real data
now i've looked at this uh i guess more
like a computer scientist
mine mic which is as a multi-agent
system so now a bird is just an agent
and they they look at their neighbors
and there's some rules that tells you
which uh bird can influence now this was
true in a previous example
uh as well maybe uh you know well
there's no point
going back but one assumes that the
birds can only see like five or six or
seven birds
that are neighbors if they cannot see
the entire thing okay so
these graphs are never complete in fact
these graphs are almost always
very sparse okay they're connected but
they're sparse
uh so there are certain communication
rules which tells you how you
exchange information and once you've
exchanged information
then each agent lives in a certain state
and there's some transitional rules that
tells you how the state changes
but the point is that the graph changes
this is very important that
not only the communication changes but
the topology changes i mean the birds
are flying
the flocks are just constantly being
rearranged okay so
um now this concept really is
ancient in physics let me show you this
little thing
so you have three metronomes and they
are placed on a piece of wood
on two cans of coke uh it doesn't matter
if it's pepsi i think and uh
so anyway they talk to each other
because this board this wooden board
actually communicates
uh the oscillations of these metronomes
and eventually they will they will
synchronize
automatically okay there's so it's a
very simple graph
and there's a prop process of
synchronization
uh this has been known for hundreds of
years
and uh and it's pretty much good theory
to explain exactly what's going on
famous uh
metronome by
the famous composer modern composer
and he's based on this principle
music and um
okay i think it's i think it's pretty
much
oh you can take it probably but it's
it's very beautiful
it's supposed to be very good uh anyway
um here's another example that i love
which is a fireflies that um
if you look at so this is a real picture
of real
fireflies a video
so what happens is fireflies have this
mating
dance and and they reach
the flash in synchrony now this is very
interesting because
again this can extend over several miles
with no line of sight
so uh sir francis drake uh observed that
in thailand many years ago
and he he he thought he was
having hallucinations because
these fireflies covered mines and mice
and they turned around the river
so they couldn't see each other and they
and
and they're and they flashed completely
in synchrony
how is that possible and uh so
so he thought he was just going now he
had
i understand he was a heavy drinker and
so he reported this to england
this phenomenon but he said maybe i'm
just hallucinating
and that's what they believed
unfortunately so his
wonderful scientific discovery was put
in
in a drawer and rediscovered hundreds of
years later in europe needless to say
the people in thailand
and in south asia southeast asia
had known this forever so for them
there's nothing but for europeans this
was a discovery
um and um calling for explanation now
just keep in mind how the communication
works here these are not stadium waves
like when you see
in stadiums whether you have this wave
these are more like circadian cycles uh
these these are cycles that are
synchronized so when they're
synchronized
if you think of communication it's it's
in it's infinite
the speed is infinite okay this is
they're actually completely sync
okay and um so it's a completely
different process
from say a diffusion process or even a
ballistic process
uh so these there are models that that
can explain this uh pretty well
and now here's the thing is that you
have these rules uh
reynolds rules uh that
this is of the inventor of virtual of
the field of virtual reality
and in in the 60s i believe he said well
i think the way to understand bert
flocking is
birds will never be too close they
should align with their neighbors they
should fly towards neighbors and they
should avoid occlusion
so let's build a model that has these
four rules
and see what happens there is no theory
of any kind he's just playing with this
but then what happened is miraculous
because
now this is not a movie from the 60s
this is a recent
movie but this is an
entirely a simulation okay and
and the thing is that it almost passes
the turing test for humans
in other words if you show an actual
flocks and
and these bogus flocks and you ask
somebody to distinguish
which is fake and which is real
this is very difficult to do and
and which is why hollywood uses these
rules uh
has become gospel now
here's something really interesting that
goes back to one of the questions about
the elephants
uh that uh joyce was uh talking about
because we failed the turing test
and we cannot distinguish be between
real vlogs and fake flocks
that that doesn't mean we're doing a
good job i mean it could be that if
birds could watch that
they would be laughing they would say oh
come on this is not flux
you're being silly maybe because we
humans are not evolved
to be good at picking out fake flux from
real flocks
so this is a i think it's a deep
question about what science
in general when when we think we're
doing a good job modeling
what do we mean by that are we just
pleasing ourselves so the movies look
good yeah but is that really the measure
um now if you want to do some theory
this is extremely difficult
um i mean and so what people do is they
get rid of three of the rules and they
keep only one
align with neighbors and so this is
first vishak and then
cocker smell rule so actually this was
done
at berkeley i believe and um
so anyway each bird has a radius of
sight
and at time t simply looks at its
neighbors
and just takes some kind of weighted
average of the
velocities and it just updates it's a
discrete time thing and it just keeps on
doing this so what i showed years ago i
mean i got
that kind of got me started in this in
this uh business and i really enjoyed it
because
uh because anyway i showed that this
graph always settles eventually
it converges to a fixed graph uh and
uh now well you'll have to go through
this uh
math thing but you have to understand
this feedback loop
which is that the network induces
updates on the velocities and once the
velocities are updated then the network
changes
so there's this feedback loop that goes
on forever
that makes it interesting and i mean
sometimes quite complicated from a
complex system's point of view
now what i showed is that you have
fragmentation typically here's what
happens your birds are flying
so semi-randomly and then they decide to
align themselves so there's going to be
a period of time where they simply start
merging into flocks
so a flock is defined as a connected
component in this graph
so they start merging uh and then
eventually they reach
uh steady state so uh
so so the the timeline has really three
three phases the fragmentations
then when they start merging and they
don't have to merge
into one vlog i mean at some point
there's number of vlogs and that's it
and then it's a steady state now
i spent quite a bit of time in my youth
doing geometry
and what really struck me about all the
work on birds flying in three dimensions
they never mentioned geometry i mean
statistical physicists
i think they hate geometry so they tried
they did everything they could to avoid
geometry so they say okay we have
velocities
and positions in three dimensions so
these are six numbers and now that's it
this is the last time we'll ever talk
about geometry
um so anyway i was pleased that actually
this involved quite a bit of geometry
i'll show you one example um
so this is a bird flying and doing its
thing any given word
at the beginning can do all kinds of zig
zaggy thing in fact birds can
collude travel another bit crazy doing
all kinds of
figure eights and stuff like that so you
can look at this in four dimensions so
the version in three dimensions but you
add time
as a space-time thing and then you
reverse time so so yeah well you know
this velocity comes
from an averaging of other birds that
came before
and this came out of this being average
over here
and then you can undo that and it goes
like this so you have this sort of
branching thing
it's not a tree necessarily i mean
there's only n birds so at some point
it will uh converge back but anyway you
have this exponential number
of paths that contribute to to the to
the position
and the heading and uh some are more
important than others
and uh but if you look at the these
leaves it in four dimensional space so
there's geometry in there
and here's what you can show that
there's there's always almost a straight
path always
after a while at the beginning there
might be no straight back but after a
while
there's always a path that's almost
straight and from these you
you can prove theorems like this that
there's a magical function
delta of t which means that at time t
if you find two birds that are a
distance
bigger than delta t then you know they
will never
ever meet again okay uh regardless of
the position this is b
of the angle uh this is beautiful and uh
and of course you you are going to need
this kind of statement if you want to
show that the flocks
converge then at some point you have to
be able to say
well you birds are either going to come
together or you will never come together
but you're not going to come back again
and again so this kind of statement
is almost a necessity uh to
do that now if if you look at a flock
when the graph is fixed uh which will
happen at the end but it might happen
in the middle also or even at the
beginning then this is a
couple oscillators so it's a piece of
mechanics of physics that's well
understood uh so now when that happens
information uh let's say one sees a
predator
and has to tell its friends this
communication will take place at
diffusion speed okay so it's pretty slow
it's it's so it's square root of the
number of
birds however there's something
interesting when they collide
when two things collide and they decide
to merge
then in that instant of collision then
uh diffusion of the i mean the
communication becomes ballistic it
becomes
linear in t not just square root uh it's
just much
much faster and you can explain this
through
the power spectrum of these coupled
oscillators when they come together but
uh
okay but we don't need to uh do this uh
the
next step which to me uh strikes me as
uh i mean something i've paid a lot of
attention in recent years
uh which also is bought from physics the
concept of renormalization
which is a dimension reduction or
whatever you want to call it
but when you have a complex system with
many many agents you're going to have at
some point
to make summaries of it to to say well
you know if you really want to
understand what's going on
uh maybe you can reduce the number of
birds here so
so if for example you could say well you
know
maybe all these all these subgroups they
almost behave
over a period of time as though they
were just one big bird
like a super bird which you might define
as being not an existing bird but
but it's a flock but it behaves almost
like like a bird and it takes
information from
so this gives you a mode of
communication that is hierarchical in
other words if you want to
to send information from here to here
you don't necessarily have to go through
the long path of birds but you can go
up to these uh super super birds uh
vlogs and and do that
now this is a picture this is a
coincidence but i love that picture
uh that um it's
it's a flock of birds but which looks
like a bird itself
it's or maybe if you believe in miracles
maybe that's a miracle but
it could also be um like the birthday
paradox just a coincidence
a ramsay theory kind of thing
uh let's see how much time do i have
left maybe i should just i don't know if
i should skip this or not
um i have like five minutes or
i think officially your time is till 1
45 so that's
uh eight minutes but maybe you want to
leave some question
yeah yeah so you know i if you don't
mind maybe i'll just
skip this and just yeah
i'd rather just simply slow down a
little bit
and talk about where i think
i'd like this thing to be going and i
think communication is a
is a fundamental it's a completely
fundamental aspect of understanding
complex systems biological
uh uh systems so
you know when people ask me what
mathematicians ask me
what's an algorithm and i
i like to say an algorithm is an
equation with memory
memory is the key role which you by and
large do not have in mathematics or in
physics
if you want to know how the solar system
works you don't need to know
what happened to the planets a million
years ago you simply need to know
what happened in in the last two seconds
where they are and how fast they go
that's all you need to know
and clearly that's not true in the
living world i mean
for one thing dna is this archive
of history but it's not just where it is
uh
the memory that's present through all
these different forms in living systems
is very complex but but it plays an
absolutely key role
in particular at all time scales now in
physics the big things when you have
different time scales to be able to
separate them
but in biology that's really it seems a
lot of the
the magic comes from the fact that time
scales are not separated they're
completely
uh embedded and so so you can ask
questions for example
i mentioned earlier circadian uh rhythms
which take 24 hours uh but when you
think about it circadian rhythms are
based
on biochemical reactions which take you
know
fractions of milliseconds so you go from
milliseconds to 24 hours
in a very reliable fashion and
and this is endogenous so it is not true
that the circadian
rhythm is determined by the sun i mean
the sun helps certainly but that's not
the reason
uh if they lock you up in a cave for
months you will still have your
circadian
rhythm although it'll be off by a little
bit so so
there's the extremely complex network of
protein reactions that
somehow and again the circadian rhythm
is a good example it has been studied
a lot and got nobel prize and all that
and the bell chemistry i think
is reasonably well understood but
there's still this very big mystery
of now it's one thing to describe every
step of the way is another thing to say
but why is this thing actually working
um
you know like if you uh design uh
biology like lego blogs
and you give the rules and then somebody
said okay i'm gonna
i'm gonna bring i'm gonna build a
24-hour
uh clock and people say you're crazy
there's no way with these lego blocks so
you can do that
it collapsed by the time you put this
thing and that's the right answer
but how come in biology actually we can
produce these very very complex things
that don't
seem to collapse there's no really
explanation and i think
the choreography of information in
particular of time
is the key thing now in biology time um
appears in my view as to be the most
difficult
variable of them all uh we're very good
at
understanding snapshots uh we understand
um
even at the level of the cell we
understand what a cell user does
at any given time now there's great
single
molecule single cell biology microscopy
and all that
but still we don't have the movies we
don't have uh
this notion of time that has that has to
be inferred
so you can use recurrent networks and
that sort of thing
but that really is a huge huge
bottleneck and it's
and i don't believe is it's just because
we don't have the measurements i mean we
don't have
the measurement but i also believe it's
because we just don't have the signs for
it
we don't we're very uncomfortable with
time
okay now there's a field in computer
science called distributed distributed
computing
which is which illustrates this notion
very well
because it's a field where you set out
to do things that seems
totally trivial but like very very
simple and then you say okay we're going
to do this
and it's going to be very simple and
they realize the
very simple solutions are all bogus and
to prove their bogus is very hard
and then to find things that actually
work very often is extremely
difficult and it seems to be inherently
difficult
uh and but that i mean
life is a child distributed system and
so i think part of the problem is we
don't have a good theory of time
i mean if time is synchronized it's
parallel okay that's fine
but when it's just done within all these
different time scales doing their own
things and
and intermingling but i think we don't
have a theory for this
and since i'm come from the world of
theory it could very well be that much
of what i'm saying is
somewhat uh or completely irrelevant
to people who actually study you know uh
biology
animals in in the field you know in the
real thing
although i do hope that at some point of
these worlds
will come together and certainly for my
part i'm totally
uh i mean at the end of the day i think
the attraction of anybody in biology is
the amazing stories that we just heard
uh in the previous talks
about these incredible animals and what
they do it's just
i don't know it's just dream like uh
material
when you can turn this into size then
it's even better
okay i will stop here thank you
so what do i do now i i unshare
stop sharing oh what's up whatever it's
worth i think the biologists are very
interested in the whole question of time
clock synchronization in cells and so
forth i mean and whether they
communicate in order to synchronize
different cells
to to synchronize their clocks i mean i
don't think they know a lot about it but
i think that's a
fascinating question yeah absolutely yes
anybody else for questions at the end of
the long day
i think there's some in the q a maybe oh
okay let me take a look
q a
although the time seem to be confused
because it's different time zones
i think there's one question here for
two from frederick why does correlation
go
to minus yeah yes it's because they end
up going in circles
so they form circles so the the long
term
i mean the really long uh uh range
correlations are
are kind of meaningless they really
should not be uh uh
should not be counted because these
birds always
they don't go straight because they have
to stay over you know eventually they
roost on
in a few trees so they just go in
circles
like merry go around yeah so i don't
think that's why we don't
even bother about these long-range
conversations
um
[Music]
so are these questions for me or for
somebody else or i think the time zones
got
complicated the questions so the
questions from the past it looks like
they are
after your talk yeah
anybody from the panel wants to say the
last word
uh maybe i i have a question probably
completely unrelated but
uh is there any link to percolation
theory yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah so the the entire theory of
criticality from the icing model
is almost isomorphic to percolation i
mean
not entirely but it's extremely similar
yes i mean certainly philosophically
it's exactly the same phenomenon yes
i shouldn't say exactly the same
phenomena because uh but
but the the critical probabilities all
of these corresponds to the critical
temperature so
yes uh but again i think that
the um from my point of view the um
my major um not criticism because that's
not
the right word but but to me the main
limitations of this entire theories
or living system is the assumption of
equilibrium
that these are theories that are
inherently based on equilibrium now i
know you can extend them
slightly outside of equilibrium yeah i
know but that's not philosophically
they're not
they're not designed for that they are
designed for equilibrium
and life is almost the definition of not
be being in equilibrium you have
constant production of entropy through
the
absorption of free energy into work and
that's
just the very basic system of life so i
think when you take very short range
snapshots uh over small time
windows then the assumption of
equilibrium i think makes sense
yes and you can because there you can
easily factor out
the non-equilibr equilibrium part as
some
modes of your system that but otherwise
you just cannot sell so i think these
are the limits of this statistical
mechanics approach
i think it was great first day well i
really loved you thank you so much for
inviting me again and for all the uh and
i'm much looking forward to the talks
tomorrow
yeah me too and mikhail you're gonna be
on first thing in the morning
it's going to be first thing in the
evening but yes that's true you have a
whole day
ahead of you so i think
thanks again and see you tomorrow good
morning
thank you everyone thank you